Hi, this is Mike from Mike and Bottom
Reviews and howto. And on today's video,
we're going take a look at the Intel Arc
B580.
Now, this graphics card has been on the
market for a little while. It actually
came out in December 2024. And actually,
I've had this one since approximately
January. I think I got it in one of the
sales it was on, maybe even at the end
of Christmas, and I haven't really used
it. So, I figured it's about time that I
actually put it into a system and put it
through its paces. being that there's a
lot of conversation at the moment both
in our discord and also on the internet
in general about what graphics card
should you buy for around about £250.
Now, this one actually retails at the
moment here in the UK and this is June
2025 for £259
from overclockers.co.uk
and I think that's actually where I
picked this one up from. Whether or not
it's a good value proposition at the
moment is very debatable. Now, we could
talk about specs and run through all
that. Essentially, this is a 12 GB card.
It is PCI Express Gen 4 X 8 and it does
appear to have somewhat of an overhead
in the driver. So, if you are rocking a
slightly older system on PCI Express Gen
3 or Gen 4 or a lower-end processor or
an older processor, then potentially
this may struggle a little bit, which is
one of the key reasons why people are a
little bit hesitant, I think, about
picking up one of these graphics cards.
Now, I've actually been testing this on
my system today, which is actually using
an Intel Z890 chipset and also is using
a Core Ultra 200 series 245K. So, a
pretty modern CPU. This also has a TDP
allegedly of 190 W. Now, for some
bizarre reason, even in my testing
today, I've never really managed to get
it much above around about 100 120. So,
this is effectively running a very
similar kind of wattage to something
like the older Radon RX6600
8 gig cards. And actually, they do
pretty well and a relatively decent
budget pickup for somewhere under the
£200 mark. So, is it actually worth
getting an Intel ARC B580 in 2025 or
beyond if you're looking at spending
around about £250? Now, there are
actually quite a few options available
at that sort of price point. We've got
the Radon RX 7600 at around about £240.
We've also got the older RTX 3060 12 gig
for around about the same price, about
£240 here in the UK. You've also got the
newer RTX 5060 8 gig at around about 260
and the RTX 4060 Storm X for around
about the same sort of price, 260 in the
UK. And if you want to spend a little
bit more, you've got the RX960
XT, which is just freshly out for around
about £270. So basically kind of bang on
the same price as this. So there's a lot
of graphics cards to choose from, and
they've all got their pros and cons. I
think the biggest con with this one is
the fact that you have got that PCI
Express Gen 4 X bus. So for older
systems, and again with that driver
overhead, it can be challenging to get
the best out of this particular GPU. So
clearly there are some dilemas to be
considered. So with all that aside,
let's take a look at the actual card
itself. The packaging is absolutely
excellent. Intel themselves have done a
fantastic job on this. Partner cards
obviously do have different variants
such as three fan models etc. Although
this one with its dual fan design, I
think they've really nailed the design.
Looking at the card, it is got a very
very nice look to it. The dual fans on
here absolutely excellent. It runs
extremely cool and quiet getting no more
than around about 70° maximum and the
fans seem to top out around about
1300400 RPM and it's basically silent in
my system. So I've got no qualms in
terms of its cooling performance and
also its noise levels. Something else
which is actually quite beneficial due
to that lower TDP is the fact you've
only got a single PCI Express 8pin power
connection. So, that is pretty useful
again for those of you with slightly
smaller power supplies or not with the
budget to have a nice beefy PCI Express
slot, then yeah, this is a pretty good
option. Also, when it comes to display
outputs, you've got four display
outputs. You've got HDMI, just one of
those, and three display ports. So,
plenty of options for driving multiple
monitors. So, if you just want to use
this in some kind of productivity
system, then it's going to be fine for
that with multiple monitor support. It
actually surprisingly does very well in
things like Adobe Premiere and also
Photoshop. So again, if those are
concerns, then productivity or kind of
real work tasks, it's actually not too
bad a shout.
Anyway, as usual, I'm wittering on a
little bit now. So, let's take a look at
some performance benchmarks. I've
actually done some benchmarks today. All
of the benchmarks in today's video will
be running at 1440p.
I think that really is what we should be
looking towards. Obviously, if it'll run
1440p, it'll do 1080p much easier. And
also, when it comes to settings, I've
set all of the games to round about
medium or high. And also a little
splattering of ray tracing involved as
well. So, with all that said, I think
it's time to go and look at the
benchmarks. So, first of all, we'll take
a look at some of the synthetic
benchmarks. So, the first one we've got
here is going to be the Steel Nomad. and
the Steel Nomad. At the end of it, we
get a score of 3,039
points, which is about what we should be
seeing for this particular card.
Next up, another synthetic. So, this is
the Solar Bay, and at the end of this,
we get a score of 7,900
points.
Next up, we've got Fire Strike. And this
gives us a score of 14,548
points for the graphics score.
And I thought being that this card
actually supports the Intel Xes,
I thought it would be a good idea to run
a test on that. So, you can see here,
and actually in the test, it's actually
quite good. You can see we're getting
around about 130% improvement in
performance. Obviously, that is with
some kind of frame generation type
shenanigans going on, but obviously if
you're running a game which does need
that extra boost, potentially it's
there. Now, of course, you can use other
technologies with this card, such as the
AMD, FSR, etc., and potentially other
scaling technologies.
So, now let's take a look at some actual
gameplay. So, first of all, we're going
to be doing CS2. Now, this is running
with the medium preset.
And we don't have any FFX or FSR or any
of that stuff. This is just native
resolution. Actually runs pretty
decently. We're getting averages around
about the sort of 250 FPS. Although
something which I do notice with this
graphics card, and it does seem to be a
regular occurrence, is you do get
massive swings in performance. So
sometimes you could be running at a
happy 250 FPS. Other times you could be
looking at around about 100. So, you get
really big swings and dips. And also, if
you look at the actual graph there, you
can see there is the occasional spike.
And I'm not entirely sure what is
causing it. Whether it's the game
engine, whether it's the graphics card.
It does appear to be something to do
with the graphics card. I am seeing this
in numerous games, which is a little bit
disappointing.
But anyway, if you want to play CS2 at
1440p at medium settings without any
frame scaling or frame generation stuff,
then I think this is actually not too
bad at all, especially for the given
price.
Next up, we'll take a look at Cyberpunk
2077. Now, with this, we'll be using it
with the ray tracing medium preset. And
with this, we're getting somewhere in
the region of about 70 FPS. Now, my
gameplay isn't particularly spectacular
here, but it actually seems to be
running quite nicely. Again, every now
and then we do get those frame spikes or
frame jumps, which is a little bit
off-putting and potentially for some
people could be somewhat nauseating.
If we actually take a look at the
synthetic benchmark in Cyberpunk, you
can see it actually runs quite nicely
and it does appear to be somewhat more
consistent. Now, some people have said
that potentially Intel have optimized
their drivers for benchmarking.
This is somewhat evident in a lot of the
actual synthetic tests as you see it
using more wattage or more TDP. Whereas
in traditional gameplay, most games seem
to be hovering around that 100 to 120 W
rather than being at the TDP maximum,
which is 190. Now, don't get me wrong,
it's great to see a graphics card being
more efficient, but it just makes me
wonder if there's something holding this
back.
Next up, something else which I
regularly play. This is Robocop Rogue
City. Now, this also is running at the
medium preset. And with this, we're
averaging in around about 70 FPS in
general, but again, it's the same story.
The frame rates are very changeable and
also there is that occasional lag spike
which again I don't know where it's
coming from. It is quite annoying and
again potentially for some people could
make you feel a little bit nauseious.
Next, something a little bit older. So
this is Reckfest. Again, one of those
titles that I play quite frequently. Now
Reckfest being a slightly older title, I
thought it'd be best to run this with
the high preset. Again, this is at 1440p
and generally we're getting somewhere
around the 150 frames per second. Now,
again, this is one of those particular
titles where depending on which map
you're on, what sort of terrain, etc.,
then you can get very changeable frames
per second, but we are looking round
about 150 FPS, which is very, very
playable indeed. And Breakfest runs very
nicely. So, if Breakfast is one of your
titles that you play most frequently,
then you're going to be very pleased
with the results with this.
Now, where it gets a little bit
different is now if we take a look at
Recf Fest 2. Now, this is the same. So,
we're running at 1440p.
This is with the high settings also, but
we are seeing a big drop here. So, the
Recf Fest 2 engine seems to be
considerably more demanding. It isn't a
particularly well optimized title yet
because it still is in its kind of beta
phase, but with this we're looking at an
average of around about 60 fps. Again,
we are getting those lag spikes and also
we're getting big inconsistency with the
actual pacing of the frames and also the
frame rate. Now, actually when I was
playing this was um it was actually very
nauseating. I did actually have to stop
doing the benchmarking and recording and
actually walk away from the computer for
a little bit because I was feeling
genuinely nauseous which is not great
and it isn't something which I found on
a graphics card in a very very long
time. Now actually after doing this I
did come back and try it 1080p and it
wasn't a great deal better. So whether
or not this is due to the actual game
engine itself or whether it's an
inherent problem with the graphics card,
I couldn't tell you. I'm hoping as time
goes on Recest 2 improves and gets a bit
smoother. I did find it a little bit
noisier with a Nvidia graphics card as
well at some point depending on the
resolutions. So I wouldn't say this is
necessarily wholly an Intel problem, but
certainly is something to be wary of if
Rackfest 2 is one of those titles that
you aspire to.
Now, changing gears completely, looking
at Fortnite. So, this is the latest
version of Fortnite. We're running this
with the medium preset with XESS set to
the balanced preset or profile. And this
is actually great. This is running
pretty much all the time at 170 FPS. It
would appear that Intel put a lot of
time and effort into this title to make
it very smooth being it is one of the
kind of the firm favorites especially
for the esports crowd and for basically
the PC market in general. Fortnite still
has thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of consistent players all the
time. So again, this runs really nicely.
It isn't quite as smooth as some of the
times I've played with Nvidia cards. I
must say that there is still work to be
done as far as the Intel drivers go, but
still 170 FPS on average at 1440p,
medium preset. I think this is actually
pretty decent and it was very enjoyable.
Next up, Dead Island 2. Again, another
one of those titles that I play quite
frequently. Now, again, this is one of
those games where depending where you
are, the frame rate can be all over the
place. Anyway, this also suffered from
what I think is something to do with the
shaders compiling in the background. It
does seem with a lot of these titles,
the longer you play them, the smoother
it gets. And that isn't again just an
Intel thing. We do find that with other
graphics cards as well. Although it has
made me consider that the Intel driver,
especially the latest one, does appear
to take a lot longer for the textures
and the shaders to all kind of pre-cache
themselves and to get a more consistent
time. This took about 15 minutes to get
to a point where it was consistently
smooth. Again, there was the occasional
lag spikes, which again seems to be a
regular occurrence, but overall 160 FPS
for a title like this is pretty good. I
quite enjoyed it, especially when it
settled down.
Also, we've got a slightly older title.
This is Far Cry 6. This is running at
the high preset without RT on. It was
very basic RT in this anyway, so I
decided to leave it off. It still looks
really nice. This we're looking around
about 120 FPS when we're kind of just
mosing around. There is a lot of
textures going on here, a lot of detail.
when you look up at the sky or anything
going on or slightly smaller areas, you
can get up to 160 170 FPS, which is very
similar to what we were seeing in both
Dead Island 2 and also Fortnite. Runs
really well. And if we look at the
actual Far Cry benchmark, and follow
that through. Again, you can see it's
pretty smooth, but again, this is one of
those things where the game is running
on Rails. There's very little to
actually get in the way, and we are
seeing those little frame spikes
periodically. it does seem to be a
consistent thing. Whether or not it's my
system, whether or not it's just the
Intel drivers that are out at the
moment, I honestly couldn't tell you.
And if you are actually an Intel ARC
A770 or B580 owner and you you have
these titles and you have the latest
drivers, please do let me know in the
comments section how yours is fairing
because this just feels a little bit
wrong to me.
So there you go. There is a look at the
Intel Arc B580 graphics card. I am very
much in mixed mind with this. I actually
find this to be arguably worse than the
A770 which come before it, which was
slightly more expensive. But you'd think
that being this is kind of effectively
the replacement for it in its price
point that this should be doing better.
I think personally and also if you look
at other older graphics cards and this
is not really just anything isolated to
Intel both AMD and Nvidia are struggling
with this at the moment especially on
the kind of the more budgetori
orientated cards when you can pick up
something like the old RTX 3060 Ti which
in general is going to be faster than
this card. Yes, we do only have 8 gigs
of VRAM. But again, if you're looking at
1080p, 1440p with slightly older games
or you're happy to put down to either
medium or high presets, then the 3060 Ti
is probably still a good shout and you
can pick those up for somewhere in the
region of about 120 to £160.
So round about £100 saving at least and
better performance. Arguably less future
proof, but depending on what Intel do in
terms of drivers and also sorting out
some of the frame pacing issues,
potentially the RTX 3060Ti might be the
way to go. Or again, if you just want a
graphics card which is just going to
slot in and work, maybe go for something
like the RTX 4060 or even the 3060 12
gig, which is going to still have that
frame buffer and still have a lot of the
performance that this has got anyway,
but you're likely to pick it up at much
lower price if you're buying it on the
used market or you'll pay exactly the
same on the new market. Anyway, I was
hoping to be more positive about the
B580.
It's a nice looking card. Intel are
doing a pretty good job in terms of this
being their second generation of
graphics card. So obviously Intel and
AMD have had a lot of experience and
have a lot of time to kind of tune their
drivers. It's just a shame they can't do
better in terms of pricing at the
moment. But if you're looking for around
about the £250 mark and you see this
around and it's available in stock, then
it's certainly worth a look. But I
certainly would consider the other
options on the market. So there you go.
That's my thoughts on the Intel B580.
Hopefully you've enjoyed the video. If
you have, smash the like button if you
want to see more content like this on a
daily basis. Maybe consider hitting
subscribe and also that chime
notification. That way you've been
future video releases. But for now, I've
been Mike. This is Mike's unboxing
reviews and how to. And hopefully we'll
catch you in the very next video. Thanks
for watching.
[Music]